what's up guys Greg here John here it's
Super Bowl Sunday so you know what that
means several reactions will be coming
your way
and apparently there was a Captain
Marvel big game DP slow dude I got oh
well John I had a shot of vodka because
you know everyone else all of our
friends are at Super Bowl parties and
we're here so we gotta have fun somehow
now on by getting drunk with trailers
instead of seeing what the scoreboard is
on everything else
anyhow let's just watch this John we've
seen a lot of Captain Marvel lately know
uh yaha chemistry
ha
slaughtered and it is
[Music]
we already got our tickets while ago got
them the day of pretty cool trailer that
was cool hey you actually get some legit
teaser Maria Rambo and cab Marvel's
chemistry here and as well as talked for
like in the comic book fans wanna see
more of her and you actually get to see
an actual glimpse of them bonding you
know being badass Lee my favorite
moments of her and all these trailers
have been her actual interaction scenes
where there's a cure for that yeah not
just like the singular lines you know
what are they saying in this trailer
this in higher faster higher faster yet
higher for the faster famous she's
saying harder better faster stronger
yeah I mean a few other different words
but kind of yeah I mean I actually
really like the way they took that and
they made it sort of this repetitive
motif with the music for the trailer
like yeah you know it just seemed like
something a little bit different for
them to do that was kind of fun and
creative and I mean you're getting a
whole lot of just promise of action from
this you know this this last image kind
of reminds me of the first Iron Man
movie in a way where it's daytime and I
mean here she's like destroying jets
which kind of issues the storage it must
be like a Kree jet or something she's
gonna go all out and freaking
annihilates just a u.s. plane right here
is just a Southwest Airlines
she's our new hero but she's murdering
the pilots regular everybody on that
plane is an imposter it was just a bunch
of that same old lady but do you
remember the first Iron Man where Tony
started as a couple of jets going after
him and it's daytime and he's flying
around it just kind of reminds me of
that little harkening back just a little
bit and even get a split second moment
here with ben mendelsohn leading a crew
of people going after them yeah man
Nolan Sorento trying to take over the
Oasis
I'm really excited for this movie man
cool cool little 30-second Super Bowl
spot right here
I enjoyed it enjoyed it yeah not as
gratifying as the end game one of course
but you know what's the exact opposite
approach yes like restraint and
somberness and this is just like kick it
out you can ask man yeah alright guys
well thanks for watching subscribe to
the real rejects click the notification
bell and I'm sure we'll be covering a
little bit more as the day goes on